with nothing years old two years
financials development projects is
turning up into luxury apartments
he's got stabbed he's 21 it is all wood
and in this interview is gonna be
sharing exactly how he did it is mindset
and what we learn from coming on the
crash course and the training with me so
you need to stick around for this
interview
enjoy James hang on the show man do you
like one of the shining stars of the box
investors at cabin a because your every
crash course killing in property and
your how long met Peter I'm 20 now I say
I say so it's cray-cray it's not it's
not normal kind of normal people in
government and we've got the sword deals
that you've got going through obviously
each month changes from month to month
deployment what's been the most
impressive deal that you've done back in
March
yeah about three four weeks after last
better than Wednesday
I saw the warfare of 60 houses yeah and
my father's feeling that was 3% of
purchase price which was 60
65 grand in one deal is that a new bank
it was and what's happened to it okay so
people do those kind of deals you're
doing it's all volume I'm making 65
grand one deal then reinvest me into
proper tell you like people are going to
thinking like that okay
clearly your background you know you've
got a really wealthy family it's being
handed to you want to play maybe you've
taken over the family business they've
took years to build is that the case no
no like my parents were never against me
they were like a drag on my January but
they never support me financially they
support me thank emotionally I get
behind the always encourages to do more
and a locust or than one behind property
they're buying me so that that's
invaluable by never has all the sort of
spirit my Osment than I did wasn't given
money to get into it and income from
investing background and income with
assets behind me I built this week from
the ground up it's not like 200 pounds
you know join the cabin in the deer for
about 15 grand them to death
so you have 15 more happening to death
join the Academy surely some people had
some things to say about that
no they did it but at the time already
taken alone is what they're going to do
they kind of realized well and people
have you know you never understood do
you can say yes you can say no I don't
listen to you yeah well whatever I'm
gonna do I'm just going to do anyway so
they they knew that I decided to know
why you've done this just make it work
and we may as well encourage you
yeah so you don't fail as we rather see
you succeed then to try and undermine
you I was a stupid decision because when
you cannot win as Wednesday I think we
do need to you about seven months ago
but you are only life's off a few months
into you journey and I think some of the
comment people make
is some of these skeptics or saying I'll
come back when you've got more deals
come back when it's a bit we'll try and
test it
you're just fresh off of a course excise
it come back in six months or so which
is which is the purpose with is it to
you what what are the ingredients that
to get this or successfully because most
people want to make two thousand a month
so they quit their job and that was
really they should roll yeah so talk me
through the ingredients to how you build
your success and then what happened well
I initially you go to betray you going
to need trained you need to know what or
is it good deal and I've got a few
people who find those for me I'd say one
in ten actually stack right even that's
people who have been trapped and it just
takes practice getting into that so you
get training that practice that and
implement that faithfully never give up
never give up yeah I was making full run
off at the time I was doing well I've
had some early success the fresh off of
course I was height yeah so I have an
initial motivation but after that it
begins to self yeah because you're not
only every week you're not around these
people and daily basis when you get up
in the morning you know there's no one
there something was not there
shouting my aim to go to the deal
whatever you have to you have to begin
to college your mind a motivating
yourself to do these things and everyday
it's not my battle necessarily but you
choose to make it about and to power
through and just to get everything done
and I'll say last seven months the
biggest thing is just keep going keep
done and things happen if you're in a
tight spot we got a race very very
quickly you know you just have to buckle
down a few others yeah
yeah you must chose the property
investors Academy with with ourselves
it's most people your plan about be
going down traditional education at
University and it's funny because people
will spend forty thousand pounds of
university study art or drama and
everyone says oh that's okay yeah but
you went into fifteen thousand pounds
worth of dads on self education yeah
with no parenting but then there's also
no guaranteed University what is just
perceived guarantee that when you get
when you get to read gonna get a job
yeah but the thing is people pay for
active on University in that hope to get
a job which is then going to give the
money
how about justice people up on your
straighter than my name yeah but why do
people think it's what are the people
would be so much more opposed to a young
person going to unaccredited self
education such as what you did without
training as opposed to University I also
don't know because if anything you think
all they younger so they've got less to
lose yeah you know if it does go wrong
versus I like to build it back up again
I think it's society culture by the
government and everybody who are in this
country they don't want you to be
successful
what's a brainwash it's good heart but
it's it's ingrained in your mind from
the day you were born and don't get me
wrong occasionally if you want to be a
doctor yeah you need the certificate
enough you need to go down that route
but if you just want it if you want to
be a businessman if you want to make
money you want to be rich or the
property investor the universities is
probably the worst no doesn't make any
sense at all and listen gone are for me
when I was thinking do I
it's before our profits when I said to
myself was you know I don't think I
wanna go to it's good let's do something
else
on one condition and that is in three
years time when I'm gonna graduate from
UT what everyone earning that what a
good job I'm doing as long as it is at
least as good as well better than one or
not undergrads need a gradual then did
you go to college I did so when did you
finish an education was 80 and what did
you study a college math physics he
patted it down I enjoyed it but if I put
it not do not go to property or 16 so if
you went back you couldn't even go to
college
also part of education was just fun yeah
but in real life usually what happens is
as Robert Kiyosaki you say is the the
eight star students work for the C and
the D students and the CD students of
the people that run the companies in it
because they told us yeah it's all the
other jobs as soon as you try it you
realize a white kid that's the reason
because because they fail in school they
can't go down the University academic
road yeah so then forced to go down a
lot of our society what do you makes you
friends just a church and general people
that are your age
cuz you're not that you typical running
almost 22 you're not a typical 21 year
old yeah what do they make of you France
it's meant it's meant it's like my close
friends under 10 sport they love
you know civil mindset many different
things or in a property of a similar
mindset about growth and self-reflection
that's great
yeah family great there are few peopie
think ledger source is a dream but it's
not my dream because you're actually
making the money yeah what's a dream for
that I'm like yeah well it's still a
dream for me it's my reality fine with
the other things so I still have that
same sensation just believed understand
where are the people that the government
criticized you say oh yeah but you've
now got a lot of tax don't haven't
spoken to our people we get way better
tax rate I could work less hours but
winning your bare tax per course follow
the rules exactly which people don't pay
much tax relief says it will see but
yeah it don't come what how much tax
well the rules are there people have to
follow so I don't get a fair I think
that there is when you don't pay tax is
because you follow the rules and by
following the rules you're actually
doing what what the government want yeah
in a way so the people that get crippled
by tax hidden to be people that are
uneducated yeah well we're here sucking
up side the the poor in the middle class
are the people that play most actor
which you know don't really
what's that when taxes originally by
design yeah but the thing is you be an
entrepreneur all the training that
you've invested it with men what is that
it's a tax file it's it doesn't make an
acceptable effective age of 90 if I stay
at hotel yeah then you go out for dinner
with your business partner the other
yeah each one that off as well
yeah so you just keep writing all this
stuff up yeah if you can't if you if you
have to pay for something yourself
I probably shouldn't pay for it it's
sort of specially now I mean he's been
even when I'm going and doing business
trips across the world don't get me
wrong I'm having a good time yeah we do
those well but but but it's a tax
write-off if I'm flying to Miami to be
grateful are down and then do business
and that it's a tax while yep so that's
something again how did you guys connect
what happened there the eviction man the
eviction it's so good I say regardless
of the 20-grand of them was a veil
enough people to win that we most value
that anybody got the same thing yeah
have one point yourself in those
positions makes you feel like when I
went into it I was like I have
Bell chiming my comfort zone for a while
and I wanted things you grow right now
and I went in there and I was very much
now I'm looking for the next thing
and I'll keep giving you stuff don't you
worry about that
so just parallelism in the eviction was
a challenge that we get for kalianan
versa you got a lot of height know about
that yeah we all do yeah you do that
today but that's part again this apology
for anything is people were saying about
you online
are you done are you doing useless but
it's like you still making pretty good
money doing property yeah so yeah you
have from Google and stuff yeah oh but
bar talking people that have got
millions of pounds saying James I want
you to be our designated deal sorcerer I
want you to do that millions of pounds
tell a lot of your property investor who
want a property investor I think yeah
I've never told anybody
why would a foreign investor things work
yeah there's a balance between you
finding them and then finding you and
you never agreed that which was going to
be so yeah just tell people you're doing
start putting yourself in places where
you it's going to happen if you're in a
meeting but if you're in the center of
London and network
yeah there we go it's when your crash
courses or success resource event I
becomes lease most of all the times to
go in that weather find out who's that
because it's like your brother success
resources brand that have attracted in
these people are flying
I hate twelve hours you're literally
bringing them to the country for me and
I can just tell other and then what the
ring and benefits and education services
yeah and that's one of the things that
you do is while you go to all the
training programs you must have
investing or a while it's yourself yeah
yeah basically any programs we've got
going you will be our registry yeah and
before it's available on you'll say I
will bring out something yeah as the
Academy
DRD of a crash course in any trips that
we're doing you just there yeah so what
I mean and then learning that you're
making
you don't be spending on yourself you
know okay fast pejoratives realist you
invest it and what do you invest ammonia
these days
fire it refines the elements oscillators
at read to essays as well yeah did in
one yeah how much you making on those
two makes great yeah you do a lot of
momentous like we did it together yeah
talk talk to me about the deal we've
just done that's a really nice house you
know I send out a list some reason it
wasn't so I think it's a cash flows and
as a buyer for everyone out to
Pennington by the Fourier ground and I
initially said the biomat 16 grand
reefer
so 548 yeah spend how much on it 1616 do
it not so it's now beautiful so then all
together we put in 54 54 plus some start
a little bit and then the new value is
85 85 what a cracker it's a really nice
house or the best bit about that I said
well you are tuned our three brand-new I
took the Builder weeks ago 50 gram 60
pounds 50 50 pounds every fan said that
they paid off the interest for you yeah
$50 so I get that you're going to put
money into a do you get more money out
but some people say yeah but you need
the money to start with divided but you
don't I don't someone else so in this
case what my clients seeing 100 into the
deal yeah and then you're paying me
interest so what would honor the father
get myself yeah it's it's only down to
you what you want to put your money into
you're still making a great risotto I'd
say why don't I have myself because I'm
gonna be bothered to drive there and as
you start buying loads of houses and
find a house just take a little bit of
work you're gonna never see anybody
you've got it so I just thought you know
what you found it
it's a great little house the numbers
are very small I'll just put the money
and I'm happy to receive a return
investment and it's quite high when you
paint it's what high is fun but then
hundreds of files yeah any more
yeah I'm for me just works I can pay the
room I trained we have the deal of a
multi-species people say to me they say
Samuel you selling people dreams telling
people where you can buy houses without
use any of their gonna it's like a nice
ending people change
I'm giving people the friggin money to
do that you're giving people the dream
I'm giving people the Gummidge I'm
giving people the money I've given
people dreaming the first place by but
that's not setting someone a dream and
it's so possible
it's so real without the reason I give
it to the people is because I'm an
investor and an investment to see a
really high ROI and I'm an investor with
property but I'm also an investor with
people and if I see people taking
massive action that leave successful as
an investor I want to spend more time on
the successful people cuz you get
orbitals yeah because I'll never give
you Berman you're going to invest it so
well you're gonna get such a and I'm
gonna see you grow as a person I don't
want to spend my time or wonderly on
losers yeah and if people come up to me
and say and I can't make the crash
because it's too far but can you come to
my house no I can't go to your house I'm
going to spend my time on people that
are serious on people that I know that
when I spend my time with them it's
gonna create a story it's gonna create
success it's gonna create significance
yeah because I've kind of got past the
point of wanting to be successful for me
are more about being significant now so
I think he was John Maxwell who said
that when you've tasted significance
success it loses its taste
yeah except for there now on that point
I just wanted to subtract big people you
know I'd rather have a hundred big
people like you then than thousands of
people the crash courses yeah yeah I've
given up trying to fill menus yes and
the people a week two days another one
this week and you mention about time yes
yeah I would say yeah you're going to
drive me down
yeah and I appreciate for some people
there will be a line there is a line you
can't just cut those people out yeah
yeah
the gym resident you are the parts of
the five members there's some people you
can spend two minutes with but not two
hours so I'm really sorry we spent two
days with ya and so we can expect you
seconds with honest I'm silly if you
work with people and you can't stand
them and that's so negative it bring you
down smile shake the hat and then you
can still be friendly but have to stick
around and if someone of your family's
bringing you now don't go stay at the
house for the weekend you can still go
to spend two hours of them every once a
month but just limit just really good
advice and also we focus on expands you
know if you say
because you're negative you know people
can look to me sometimes to say what are
the people like in America you know I
used to find what people like and I'll
say they're probably the same as the
people in England because if you go all
of these England you really lose your
voice well but if I don't stick I don't
see that the awesome people of energy
they're happy if you attract what you
are you know you want to do you want to
on a beautiful partner or a great
business partner don't ever try to find
the correct business partner try and be
someone that would attract a great
business partner I've been coming on
yourself yeah and you probably find the
person you're after at the same places
where you go is there to run the same
thing yeah you actually though through
the Academy for the addiction I'd make
it like twice it wasn't so we got to the
invention we had a proper chat with and
when I was working on through stuff with
him it was just it was very clear from
day one they he was someone who
as well as he does and he was a lot of
synergy how much is all property
property so you came with a crash course
you learned how to do it you went into
debt oh no all the advanced trainer you
could as people say to me you know all
is the crosswalks just a sales pitch to
try and get people's to dfangs trying it
does I don't know so it really does a
deepening sales is a fantastic I love so
awesome that's the first second thing is
it's just about tell you what the time
you get round to Senate you're like oh
what was gonna be because I've received
so much you actually not a fair enough
even if you don't want those on for a
full episode people I mean going to
always adventures to watch themselves
[Music]
I'll do it this way suffice like 20
hours yeah I mean the crash courses so
content-rich and it's I don't like gotta
hop up there and if I didn't make an
offer at some points I hate those who
either want to do advanced training
you'd be proud I'll be doing people a
disservice because sometimes people go
to the crash course and they go become
financially free just after the crash
course and that's great but a lot of
people they feel they need that extra
support on that extra option yeah you
know I feel like I need more training
that and that's why in the last year
I've spent half a million pounds on my
own education because you serve
educationally because you believe
education yeah yeah so those people say
you only bank one about education cause
you run in the training businesses
actually give them around right I've run
a training business because I believe in
education sure
so biggest advice thing that someone's
died now maybe we've never made that
brand new to this what are their steps
or console equals 1 2 would be just
absorb as much information as you can
around property around investing around
the mindset success you'll get the
skills in the crash course to do the
Academy so that you'll get all that
you'll get your toolbox if you don't
know how to use the tools in it
that's when and how to continually do
that the database
just the mindset of the rich ladies so
so powerful me none of the podcasting
last week specific about the habits of
wealthy we begin to learn and use our
podcasts reads now it's the stuff they
don't teach you in school they don't
know you live scoring you know nothing
about people
yeah yeah yeah it's nice
join the journey by and you never want
to see money in the bank if you've got
loads of money in the bank you meet you
doing something wrong because not for me
should be investing property oh yeah
watch what you say that what do you
think it should be miserable to bother
about straight in the back by a
fantastic time yeah lioness it's one of
the first things you learn about the
rich is when everyone else is dead
that's when you get my fuel buyer so
yeah I mean I just
until I decide that I don't want to grow
anymore like it's going as fast as
possible yeah yeah that's so interesting
about wicked people which we don't have
usually don't have a loads of cash on
them and money in the bank because they
know the board money disappears yeah and
if you've got just - what's up - all the
time and you've got lots of money in the
bank just sitting there bored it
disappears yeah because suddenly Oh a
boiler breaks all of this where was what
you want that money and you invest it
into yourself and into property and
business and we put it into park if you
can you invest it and it's in assets
that's what it then produces and if you
reinvest them you know wanna be a
situation where you've got a board money
hanging around you know no it's one of
your friends if you're if your money's
negative on board your community
Yasmani view it was one of your five
people you keep around every aspect of
your life yeah should be positive into
growth focused positive people don't
focus on saving if you want three grand
a month for maximum sales to focus on
making more and every single occasion
always say folks those evil it's such a
subtle change it takes a bit to finally
understand when you get in you're always
focused on pro so let me ask you a
question that would you rather be happy
or rich I think you can be both
educators but you know what though being
an ant man instead of it all that is so
important because everyone everyone says
that you want to be happy what you want
to be rich or do you wanna have lots of
properties and the big business or
daymo be rich is pretty easy easy
yeah ten years ago yeah yeah
but just going online again little free
resources really feeling you need to go
to the training programs and I mean what
do you think it's possible to learn the
skills but if your mindset I think
although it's possible the fact that
you're not willing to spend money on it
willing to invest in yourself you're not
willing to well you are willing to wait
then I don't think you'll ever make yeah
I don't think you'll ever do well I
think it's a loser thing to say I don't
need to go to the course I'm going to
read the books got the podcast see
I think suddenly you need to say and I
also think that it's like saying I don't
need a driving instructor I read the
book the theory but you've gotta get in
the driver's seat and have it be here
and that's what we do our training
programmes we let people have a go say
let's go find a deal let's have a look
at you deal even on the crash course
yeah
it's letting people have a go and if you
said I want to be a doctor if I don't go
to university I want to be even a
hairdresser I don't want to pay for the
education I just I just want to just
have a go if the real work you're gonna
cut people's ears and making mistakes in
the property business it can be very
costly so I just you know when people
say you know I don't want to attend the
crash course I don't want to attend it's
just like dude yeah yeah the bank did
pay for it and it's the exact same plans
for the future that I'm sure you'll be
back the next year on Wednesday they
probably again because what we don't
want is Wednesday's if so what I know
you came on about seven months ago but
if someone goes on they're just way more
have more stories then we can bring them
back on why not so what's what's the
plans over the next or six twelve months
development follow system is the source
of company
a high quality that diesel began and I
go straight to developments we've got
400 of them are all fully financed test
it we say development you just mean it
always wants a house the two parts and
then the biggest ones is very big and
then average size to Plattsburgh
yeah and you've got you've got important
that going on right now
yeah it's fantastic I'm really excited
and I'm glad to be in the journey I'm
glad to have you on you have to be
massive out there and we're driving
that's a good job
[Music]